it is with this report the european parliament has
positioned itself as a
determining factor in the attribution of the partnership
between equals Progressive and ambitious
establish a multilateral partnership at the eu-africa summit
make a
genuine will to build in
permanent dialogue it is only the lasting ones who
denounce the african peoples  and
European peoples Europe and Africa must
free themselves from the relationship between donor and
commercial client conditions for the
two continents that confer not only
as equals will in sovereignty but
also in the means of recovery
available this is going to be easy but
with dignity, decency and commitment is
a  fundamental strategic sign that
possible to materialize
[Music]
I'm not going to train in yesterday don't
see if it hits the letter p' Metralha stay
type in the season I used the basketball game
enjoy it there in mine don't take it in the face there
we here man everything  that I retained inside
the because Rita connected here, right, only there
for the funeral of one now because I'm going there
var my clothes was fixed and the respective
operation here means that it took him
solutions to have about the distribution
of rural life i
bom vivant Heavy rotation All our
Friends at the world in terms at Any
moment now in motion and Cloud
vaccination strategies and Acceleration
Speed download  everybody to catch Fish
and robotics in behavior of Africa we
hope you
I know who has this that Will really
boring about growing in the world is
growing inequalities in our society is a
Hole in the chances Of The Next
Generation to Become The Master Of Your
Destiny  leads One By One Fight stronger
And qualities and Nobody Hold On